>> Yes, of course, India can become a superpower.
That's what, in fact, we've been talking about
for the last ten years
and we've seen the rapid progress has been.
The last one year has been a blip mark not
because of India but because
of the world economy [INAUDIBLE].
What we do not really have in place totally
and need to work towards is
the total political will to make it happen.
Having the [INAUDIBLE] government in the second
session in a much
better position, will definitely help.
But at the same time, the willingness of the
executive to work with the
private sector as well as with the social
sector to make the progress
happen is extremely important.
In the private sector [INAUDIBLE] the new
enterprise of the businesses,
the people are just ready to go and want to
go.
That is also reflected in the [INAUDIBLE]
initiatives that in place
have taken.
We hope to also reintegrate that -- our total
population and youth is
totally motivated and brought together to
play a role in this progress.
It will be a five-year or a 20-year plan depending
on how well we
manage the process.
At the minimum the 20-year plan can work,
if we have a total commitment
to changing the education sector.
This is the most important reform that that
we need to put in place and
in the timeframe to 20 to 30 years it is so
possible, so possible, that
I'll be surprised if we don't achieve it.